the seaside resort of Biarritz France
the perfect spot to bring home built
custom bikes together with surfing and
art on the beach
it's the wheels and waves festival a
celebration of freedom and individuality
expressed in the bikes each
one-of-a-kind each built with love and
devotion this is you know a place where
everybody can bring whatever they got
what they have done in their sheds at
home and it's interesting to see all the
different the creativity that people
actually brings up on the show like this
the motorcycles actual make is of
secondary importance every brand is here
from harley-davidson to Beemer
this mountain man from the Alps has
equipped his bike to round up cattle
he's deliberately let the fuel tank rust
and included provisions for his liquid
needs in the high valleys BMW Motorrad
has chosen this very special venue to
debut its own interpretation of a
scrambler the BMW Concept path 22 based
on the AR 19
the oven well a stinking guard of BMW
Motorrad explains that they've set the
frame higher and given it the right
exhaust system on wheels 17-inch and
back and 19-inch in front with rims
especially milled for this motorcycle
it's got a little single seat with a
hump in the back a scrambler is a
motorcycle outside the established
standards and conventions performance
takes a backseat to style and
originality
the BMW Concept path is powered by the
typical Beamer 2 cylinder boxer engine
with card and shift drive while such
typical scrambler features as lug tires
a larger front wheel extended shocks and
high mounted dual can exhaust get the
bike effortlessly through sand and
gravel
the climax of the wheels in waves
festival is the Punk speak race where
the new BMW Concept path 22 can strut
it's stuff
you